An R2-D2 pepper mill and cologne that makes you smell
like Play-doh.
It's episode 20 of LÜT.
This wallet
looks like a lot of hundreds and these
bars of soap from ThinkGeek
contain caffeine, really. Each shower you
take delivers the same
as a cuppa coffee, because caffeine can
be absorbed through your skin.
Soup up your phone's camera with
wide-angle telephoto and fish eye lenses
all in one contraption and then charge
your phone via USB
by installing sockets with USB ports.
Protect it with a heat-sensitive
backing that responds to your touch, like that little touch you add to your outfit by wearing
a tie that says joystick,
pong, Guitar Hero, Tetris or Duck hunt.
Your kids can stamp animal footprints
with these sandals. And this stamp
allows you to print over 2,000
different Japanese emoticons.
Also on Japan Trend Shop, a home planetarium
that project ten thousand of the stars and
galaxies seen in the northern hemisphere
onto your wall. These holiday cards for web
developers are stamped with the recipe
for eggnog
in Python, JavaScript, Relieve and PHP.
Pour some beer out of a skull pitcher
and make important life decisions with
this magic 8 ball
pen.
Then relax on your space invader couch or
sit on the toilet next to your dragon
toilet paper tyrant
and rest your head on the pillow that
makes you look like you're on the cover
of a magazine.
Do you like jewelry and engineering?
Well, grab yourself a gear-ring and how about this LED
faucet that tells the temperature of water
without getting you wet.
Blue is cold, green is warm and red is hot.
Hot like this heart necklace.
It's anatomically correct.
Cool down some ice cream scooped into
stackable cylinders
and decorate your body things to Etsy
user project Pinup,
who makes diablo health and mana
potion earrings,
but that's not all. She also makes
amazingly creepy cameos.
Remember the brain I used in the deja
vu episode? I bought it
from Evolution, a store in Manhattan that also
has an online store,
where you can buy actual dinosaur teeth,
actual pieces of meteorites
and more.
Today's free thing is more of a DONG -
Gapminder - a really cool site that allows
you to chart global data,
like life expectancy versus income
per person by country
and even play it through time to see how
things have changed.
More videos coming soon,
especially about outer space.
Why? Because I'm here at Space Camp with
Brad and Liam
from World of the Orange. We're shooting stuff
for YouTube.com/SpaceLab. The
only cool thing I've seen so far is this
pin they gave me right there.
Just
kidding. It's gonna be awesome.
And as always,
thanks for watching.